Australia’s Great Barrier Reef: 133,000 square miles! Nearly 400 different types of coral!
And it’s all dead. Wait, no it’s not.
Yea, it is. Well maybe a little.
Depending on who’s posting on your Facebook
feed, the Great Barrier Reef is either doing
just fine or it’s teetering on the brink
of destruction. So should you cancel those
tickets to Australia? Is there even anything
left to see?
A coral reef is an underwater structure made
of, you guessed it corals. And while those
corals might look like a collection of snazzy-looking
rocks, they’re actually the exoskeletons
of living invertebrates. They eat, reproduce,
grow, all the stuff anything else living in
the water does. They also drop dead if the
conditions they’re living in aren’t quite
right. Conveniently, corals have a pretty
clear way of showing their health. If everything
is A-OK, the corals will all be colored earth-tones,
like 1970s living room furniture. When
they get sick, they can become fluorescent.
And when the coral turns white or becomes
“bleached,” well, then that means it’s
dying and that its recovery is in question.
So, is The Great Barrier Reef dead or not?
Well, it suffered a massive bleaching event
in each of the past two years as a result
of rising ocean temperatures due to global
warming. The extreme nature of 2016’s bleaching
led to this: a slightly satirical obituary
for the reef that wound up going viral. That
caused environmental reporters to try and
stop the spread of any misinformation clarifying
that, while the reef was in poor health, it
wasn’t actually dead.
So, then it’s fine, right? I mean, you also
might have seen this in your Facebook feed,
a report that UNESCO, the United Nations body
that lists the Great Barrier Reef as a World
Heritage Site, did not put the reef on its
“List of World Heritage Sites in Danger”.
Well, that decision was actually criticised
on social media, pointing out that the reef
is absolutely in great danger, something UNESCO
itself has even previously suggested.
So who’s right? Scientists? UNESCO? Outside
Magazine? Well, the bleaching events are not
normal, before 2016 there were only two bleaching
events in the previous 17 years. And while
a reef can recover from bleaching, that can
take up to a decade, making the back to back
events that much more concerning. Fortunately,
Australia is trying to do its part, allocating
over a billion dollars over the next five
years to help repair the reef as part of its
Reef 2050 plan. And that’s no surprise,
given the tourism it attracts and its estimated
financial value. So no, the Great Barrier
Reef is not dead. But ⅔ of it is damaged
with its recovery in question. Now if someone
just shared this video instead of those other
articles, we could maybe all get on the same
page. Please share the video.
Hey, the ocean’s full of cool stuff like
coral reefs, find out about its mysterious
Twilight Zone in our new series, Science in
the Extremes. Don’t forget to subscribe,
and keep coming back to Seeker for more videos.